I asked multi-millionaire Daniel
Priestley what every entrepreneur should
do before they start their own business
and here is what he said it's massively
useful to join someone else's startup
like I would highly recommend that to
absolutely anyone so here's what goes
wrong with a lot of young people they go
to careers fairs and all that sort of
stuff it's only big corporates that
exhibit so they end up being funneled
down the big corporate path so when you
join a big corporate you have no idea
what the whole business does you have no
idea what everyone else does but when
you join a business that's four people
five people six people you know exactly
what the whole company does you you
often know the revenue you often know
the profit you often know the weekly
activity of the entire team so you get
this kind of feeling and experience of
what an entire team does and what an
entire business does and I I would
highly recommend anyone who wants to
start a business
first do two years working inside
somebody else's small business